First of all,
I like to say that you're my favorite
person ever in the world,
but my question is,
do you think we can build our own
monitor day?
I'm Frankenstein,
like sewing together body parts and
somehow reanimating it.
Do you think that's possible because you
seem like the person to ask this anyway.
Thank you so much.
I hope to see a big think
reanimating people from different body
parts.
Probably not,
but something even more amazing is about
to happen in biology and genetics.
Well,
one cliff point of clarification.
Dr. Frankenstein created what came to be
called Frankenstein's monster.
The monster himself was not really
called Frankenstein.
Just a little,
a little science fiction point of
interest there.
So,
uh,
what will probably happen in your
lifetime,
just judging how old you appear on big
thing is people will be able people like
you will be able to regenerate parts of
your body using your own cells that a
technologists in medicine and genetics
are finding ways to get your own body,
to create more cells that it wouldn't,
that it didn't use to be able to create.
Like if you need a new pancreas,
you'll be able to grow your own
pancreas.
And I don't know about complex
mechanical systems like hands and
fingers,
but it doesn't seem beyond,
uh,
the technology that's being developed
right now because in my lifetime,
people came to appreciate the
significance of stem cells.
These are cells that are,
uh,
have plenty of potential.
They can be anything when you're a
blastocyst,
before you become a take on the form of
a human or what have you.
So the acronym is Crispr and the,
uh,
I know the p there is palindrome
Palindromic,
which is the same at both ends,
the same backwards and forwards.
And so people are being or finding ways,
geneticists are finding ways to get
cells to do whatever they want,
whenever they want them to do.
And it's presumed that instead of making
a monster akin to Dr Frankenstein's
fictional creature by assembling pieces
of from disparate other humans.
Instead,
you'd get each person's own cells to
create a regenerate body parts or,
or,
um,
maybe in,
in the,
in the womb,
create extraordinary people that were
extraordinarily smart with extraordinary
skills and dunking basketballs or have
you,
but the idea of taking your
consciousness and putting it in another
device or another system or another
biological,
another person,
another biological system is something
has been around for a long time.
Science fiction has got it for a long
time and I'm always charmed by the
singularity when brains,
when computers are going to be as
complex and sophisticated as a human
brain and uh,
that this,
this moment in history is called the
singularity.
And then you'll just download all of
your memories and all of your
experiences into this electronic
presumed electronic storage system.
And then you would live as long as
you're plugged in,
as long as you have electricity,
what have you.
It just seems way more complicated than
that.
And not something I would ever count on.
And I don't think you can really be a
whole person in the way it.
You seem to be here on camera without
your census,
without your eyes,
ears,
nose,
and so on,
feeling the world around you,
so called your,
your so called central nervous system,
which is part of your brain.
I don't think it's that simple to put a
brain in another body and carry on or
put your consciousness and electrical
receptacle and carry on,
but you may be living at a time when
extraordinary things will be done with
your own cells that will far surpass
anything that Dr. Frankenstein in the
story was able to do.
It's exciting.
Carry on.